aéroport montréal-trudeau jeudi soir
dernier les yeux fixés sur l'écran des
arrivées stéphane la gu et nerveux après
des semaines de démarches lui et sa
conjointe de s'apprête finalement à
accueillir dmitro oksana et leur fille
dominique a ils les ont rencontrés sur
ce groupe facebook où les réfugiés
ukrainien qui choisissent de venir au
canada peuvent échanger avec des
canadiens prêts à les héberger j en suis
content quand on regarde plus la télé et
on a deux choix dans la vie soit on
change de poste
pour s'impliquer on dit faut faire
quelque chose procédures d'immigration
test qu'aux vide et trois heures plus
tard il arrive enfin
la famille est crevé après 36 heures de
voyage varsovie cracovie barcelone et
montréal
mixte mix rigueur
mis trop était en pologne quand la
guerre a éclaté et il a décidé de ne pas
retourner en ukraine comme seul bagage
ils ont une valise et deux petits sacs à
dos et
non match battre des gosses
ou kiosque mise en place par le
gouvernement du québec on leur a donné
une liste de ressources communautaires
des informations sur l'obtention d'une
carte d'assurance maladie et on a pris
leurs cours donnés pour des cours de
francisation
puis ils ont quitté l'aéroport en route
vers cette nouvelle vie on s'est donné
rendez vous quelques jours plus tard le
temps d'assister à une autre rencontre
marquante à dorval celle de deux
enseignants de l'université de montréal
qui ont réussi à faire venir ces quatre
étudiantes de l'université de kharkiv
elles sont les premières l'ukrainienne
d'une dizaine arriver grâce aux contacts
de martin carrier qui a déjà fait un
échange à kharkhiv on est en fait très
fier d'avoir réussi à raconter ça ça a
été énormément d'embûches et on est
évidemment très heureux de recevoir ils
ont fait quelque chose magnifique et
c'est vraiment très important pour nous
l'université père à leurs frais de
scolarité et leur hébergement au moins
pour les premiers mois c'est avant tout
un geste humanitaire c'est un geste pour
aider ces étudiantes c'est un geste que
je vous dirais de solidarité envers
l'université de quartier qui a été
bombardé ici
la phrase je pense que mènerait les plus
cool que l'autre le travil parce que
pour moi c'est plus important et c'est
plus intéressant étudie tout un procès
mais pas en danger
nous les avons revues deux jours plus
tard sur le campus de l'udem les quatre
étudiantes en sciences politiques
commencent à découvrir leur nouveau
monde et s'organise avec beaucoup d'inde
parle avec nous et il dit salut qu'en
haut ça va c'est normal est ce qu'on
peut vous aider donc c'est vraiment
vraiment aux gentilles de la gentillesse
et de la générosité qui font parfois
oublier juste un peu les nouvelles de
l'ukraine et l'inquiétude d'avoir une
famille des amis près des combats
continus titre je suis le monde ne
regarde pas sur l'intégrale parce que
c'est vraiment très très difficile
marina c'est que kharkiv sa ville a été
bombardée la veille et qu'il y a eu
plusieurs morts elle même a dû fuir les
bombes c'était vraiment difficile à part
ce que
parce que c'est la guerre c'était
vraiment difficile
est-ce que je peux pas répondre à cette
question
derrière les sourires on sent ces
souvenirs qui ne s'effaceront pas mais
leur vie qui a basculé en deux mois leur
offre au moins un nouveau départ
[Musique]
pour la famille de dmitro ce nouveau
départ a lieu dans la maison historique
de stéphane à 25 km de montréal sur la
rive sud ils viennent de vivre leur
première papou québec et dominique à qui
aura six ans la semaine prochaine a déjà
droit à une vie presque normale les deux
familles semblent à l'aise ensemble
mêmes complices
très bien évidemment c'est un changement
de vie
donc on essaie de les intégrer
tranquillement exploit
[Musique]
face aux
micros communique en anglais et oksana
pour l'instant utilisent google jones
lee
déjà ils passent parfois ou français ça
c'est ma femme
ça c'est une belle femme
ils passent aussi parfois des rires aux
larmes devant la générosité de leurs
hôtes l'ouest
stéphane qui est conseiller financier
insiste plutôt sur la générosité de ses
proches bientôt leurs invités pourront
aller vivre en appartement
on a avancé jusqu'à d'ap 6100 lors on a
eu lieu hier sécheuse on a eu
des meubles pour meubler l'appartement
au complet
il a même trouvé un emploi pour dmitro
qui a hâte de travailler en attendant
dans leur chambre
le couple s'informent régulièrement de
la situation en ukraine
vendredi passé il recevait des textos de
son père tu es la nuit
limitera pas mis trop aimerait faire
venir son père au québec leur vie sera
maintenant ici vie de cette
caisse
à l'autre
google
doit regarder vers l'avant pour notre
fille elle aura beaucoup d'opportunités
ici dit oksana dominique à qui a déjà
son nouveau sac commencera ses cours
lundi à l'école du village
comme elle comme oksana dmitro comme
marina où anastasia
ils sont aujourd'hui 5 millions
d'ukrainiens avoir fui la guerre avec
devant eux une destinée qu'il n'aurait
jamais pu imaginer
[Musique]